congratulations on the song thank you so
much
massive and obviously like massively
catchy how quickly did the song come
together
thank you um i wrote it about a year ago
with two of my friends one of them
um bendick muller who's actually my
boyfriend and then our friend jason haas
and the session about probably four
hours originally and then we wrote the
second verse
six months later so what
[Music]
so when did this epiphany come about
that like
disney movies had shaped your idea of
love and romance
apparently it's something that i thought
for quite a long time
because recently my parents sent me a
video of one of my first performances
and i was i think i was about nine years
old and i was singing an original
and the lyrics were so funny they were
like
um you know if i'm gonna break the spell
i'll do it myself
because fairy tales don't leave their
pages like you know they don't always
have happy endings
like don't let down your hair rapunzel
it was like super auntie did
um and i was only nine i've kind of been
for a while that's wild like
um and how so how old are you right now
i'm 21. you're 21. so
growing up that way like i know a lot of
uh
parents who still think kind of in that
old-fashioned
disney movie sense but you want to be
here championing
this whole other thing if you're gonna
if you're gonna um
consolidate that message into like one
phrase what is it
yeah like it's okay to want to make your
child
feel like a princess um but i think the
issue is the stereotype around what a
princess
is a princess should be someone who's
strong and independent and
fights his or her own battles it
shouldn't be someone who
you know needs a prince to be saved and
you know kind of just sits around
waiting for things to happen
so how would you define um an ideal
romance and and
love now um an ideal romance
i guess a partnership where both people
really complement each other and respect
each other's
you know strengths and weaknesses and
um like make each other better together
but are also
okay apart like i don't think i don't
think
and on whoever you're with i think you
guys should just you know love
each other now obviously the song is
everywhere
have you heard from disney at all about
your track
not i've not heard from disney hopefully
they're not
too upset with me but
[Laughter]
i think it's interesting i think it
would be an interesting um
your song would be an interesting way
for them to approach
the whole disney princess thing moving
forward i think that would be an
interesting thing to
take a look at now the song gained a lot
of attention on tick tock are you
surprised
that so many people are relating to the
message oh definitely
yeah i'm surprised about all of this i
never expected any of this to happen
um it's it's crazy yeah i'm shocked
every day
one of the big trends is people doing
the uh like doing makeup like snow white
for example and then it
changing and changing and changing
what's your reaction to those do you
have a favorite one
i don't have a favorite i love all of
them i think they're so cool
especially since i know absolutely
nothing about makeup
i'm like the least experienced person
when it comes to makeup
um yeah so every time i see that i'm
just blown away they're so cool and it's
really
um it's really touching to see that like
my
song kind of inspires all that
creativity
yeah i'm curious what kind of feedback
have you like received from people
messaging you directly or commenting on
your video
about their experience with the song and
how that relates to their own life
oh my god so many positive messages it's
insane i've never been like so
filled with love before i feel like
every time i go online
it's just you know tons of people
reaching out and saying how the song
affected them um a lot of people say
they listen to it while they're doing
homework which i think is funny
um yeah maybe maybe it helps you with
your math homework so that's good
a lot of people said it really helps
them you know get through
rough times which obviously you know
makes me so so grateful and so happy
because in the end like i make music to
to try and leave a positive impact on
people
absolutely and it's doing that what have
your family and friends said about
everything that's going on about the
reaction that the world is having to
your song
they're so excited uh my family's been
supportive of me
forever they've been you know really my
rock
um with this crazy dream of mine and
they've
been like my cheerleaders the whole way
through so when this all happened
they were so overjoyed my parents were
kind of like not
surprised in a sense because they were
like yeah we knew it was gonna happen
like we believed in you though
like sitting here like freaking out like
don't know what's going on and they're
just so calm and everything
it's very sweet um yeah and then you
know my friends have been super
supportive as well everyone's been
reaching out and
saying they you know hear it playing in
a bagel shop in new york and then
like i don't know in their gym or
something it's crazy i've actually never
heard it outside though i've never heard
it on radio
and i've never heard it in a store
probably because i don't really go
outside anymore because of course but
well i mean when you're at home you
can't and you're in you're
scrolling through tick tock whatever
like you can't avoid it so i guess
that's where we are that's where we're
at right now right
yeah yeah i do i do see it on on the for
you page
quite a bit now and the funny thing
about like
um the comments under the youtube video
under your music video a lot of people
are talking about the ears
and people are like discussing like are
they her ears
what what do the ears mean like is there
symbolic
what's up with the ears was it weird to
wear them the whole time oh
funny yeah those are my favorite
comments honestly
um reading about the ears because no one
really knows
what's going on with them and i've
actually read some very in-depth
analysis
of why i'm wearing the ears and i wish
that i could say that there was a really
deep
profound meaning but honestly we were
just trying to take a bunch of disney
tropes and kind of make fun of them and
over exaggerate them
um so we decided to go with elf ears but
make them more rounded not like
you know the stereotypical pointy ones
um
and make them like a little less
stereotypically attractive
and the reason that they're on the whole
video is actually because
we spent like an hour and a half getting
them on
um there was an amazing prosthetics
makeup artist who came
and glued them to my face and then
painted them to match the color of my
skin
it was a very cool process and it felt
so weird at first just because you're
getting like glue put
inside your ear definitely not something
you experience every day
um and then the base of the video we
were filming it so quickly that we
didn't have many breaks between scenes
and we realized it was going to take
about an hour
to get them off so we were like you know
what we're just going to keep them on
through the whole thing
so i wish i could tell you that there
was some you know
deep-seated reason i was wearing them
the whole time but they were very hard
to get on and off
i love that there's a real practical
reason why they exist in the video
and people all in the comments are like
whatever it helps with the algorithm
let's just get this video out more
thought that they were my real ears for
a second there
they were like wow she has some big ears
there and i'm like
i kind of i kind of wish that they were
real they were a look
i liked them well i mean god bless some
people on there because they were also
like
hey guys like don't talk bad about her
ears like maybe she's sensitive about
them
it was really sweet
so you said it's lovely your parents
have been super supportive of your dream
but what is
like the dream what's the big dream
where do you want to see yourself
several years down the road um honestly
just to be you know as big of
an influence in the industry as i can be
both as an artist
obviously when touring is safe again um
i would love to
tour the world i haven't really traveled
very much so i would love to
you know play shows in different
countries
um that's a big goal of mine and also as
a songwriter i would love to write more
for other artists as well i write
basically every day
um sessions right now mostly on zoom and
half the time it's for my artist project
the other half it's for another artist's
project i really love trying to help
people tell their stories um the same
way that i'm
fortunate enough to tell my project
that's cool
is that pushing back sort of
anti-establishment thing i mean clearly
it's part of who you've been since you
were a kid
but is that part of your art too is that
part of the what you write about
um definitely yeah i think that it's
important to write about what you
believe in
um whatever that may be just total
honesty and songwriting is kind of
you know my main goal just because
you know you want whatever you're saying
to be super authentic and you want to
write for other people i make sure that
it's
a message i can get behind and i really
do think that music
is like the most universal language
um i think it's incredible how much it
can communicate
even if you're not even paying attention
to the lyrics just the sonics behind it
and tell such a story which i think is
super cool um
and like my goal is always to spread you
know positivity
and also to make people think i really
enjoy making people think through
um they're my lyrics i'm very lyrical
when i write so i usually start
with a concept um and just like
something i want to say
and then you know yeah if anyone listens
hopefully
hopefully people are definitely
listening
who is um who would you say
has been like maybe your biggest musical
influence like who do you love that
influences the way that you write the
way that you create even the way you
think musically
oh that's a good question i don't know
if i can pick this one there are so many
so many amazing artists and writers out
there
um david bowie is definitely one i grew
up listening to him
um it's kind of funny too because my dad
is like the biggest david bowie fan in
the whole world
and he would play him for me when i was
a child and i didn't even realize
what was playing and then you know i
started making music and i went to
college and then i really got back into
bowie and like started listening to all
my dad's favorite albums
and i kind of saw like a bit of
similarity in the weirdness and like
kind of the experimentation
that i had pulled from kind of
subconsciously um
just from listening to him you know when
i was a toddler so that one definitely
uh i love the beatles of course i kind
of use them as like a litmus test for
people if i meet someone and i like
can't really tell their vibe i'm like
do you like the beatles and if they say
no i'm always very wary because
who doesn't like the beatles
then a little more recent i would say
lord definitely
i think she's incredible i actually
wasn't a super fan until mela drama
which is funny because i know everyone
you know the first album is so
incredible and that's what everyone i
feel like gravitates towards but
melodrama kind of changed the way i
looked at production
um in relation to the top line just
because i feel like the vocal production
on that
is so incredible and then all the sounds
underneath it really just complement the
lyrics perfectly
um so i think that's kind of you know a
masterpiece of an album
you